المزيد الآن في أهم الأخبار هذه الساعة
يدين الرئيس الأمريكي السابق دونالد ترامب التهم الجنائية الموجهة
إليه بعد إدانته التاريخية
في قاعة محكمة في مانهاتن يتحدث إلى
مؤيديه في فلوريدا قبل ساعات فقط
ادعى ترامب المتحدي أن هذه مجرد
محاولة لعرقلة ترشيحه.  لعام
2024. قال أيضًا إن الجريمة الوحيدة التي
اقتبسها من أقواله هي الدفاع عن الأمة بلا خوف
حيث اتضح أن كل شخص
نظر في هذه القضية بما في ذلك وحيد القرن
وحتى الديمقراطيين المتشددين
يقولون إنه لا توجد جريمة
وأنه ما كان يجب أن يتم
تقديمها
أبدًا.  قال الجميع ،
حتى الأشخاص الذين
ليسوا من المعجبين الكبار ، إنهم قالوا إن
هذا ليس الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب القيام به ، إنه
إهانة لبلدنا لأن
العالم يضحك علينا بالفعل في
وقت سابق من اليوم الذي ظهر فيه ترامب في
محكمة نيويورك حيث توسل إليه  غير
مذنب في جميع الجنايات الـ 34
التهم التي تنبع من تحقيق في
خطة دفع أموال صامتة لعام 2016
لنجم سينمائي بالغ ستورمي دانيلز